Yeah, I grew up in a college town. It's specifically a college that's all
about science and engineering. It was a Manhattan Project outpost. There
were, you know, kids in my Boy Scout Troop whose dads had worked refining
uranium for the Manhattan Project. And
when you're a kid, wherever you grow up,
you think is normal. Maybe you've had this experience. And you
don't realize how weird it was until you
go other places and meet other
people. So I had a lot of a science and engineering mentality sort
of baked in from the very beginning. So I'll tell an anecdote that
sums up Ames, Iowa in in my youth. Okay so in my Boy Scout troop, some of the dads
came up with an idea. We did all the
normal Boy Scout things like Pinewood
Derby and whittling arrowheads and that
kind of stuff. But they came up with this
idea which was that one of these guys
worked in the AG Engineering department
he's the co-inventor of the cylindrical
hay bale. And he took some corn seeds
that were as as close to being
genetically identical as he could get.
They weren't cloned necessarily, but like
maybe all from the same head of corn or
something, ear of corn. And he carried them across
the campus to the office of another dad
who was one of these Manhattan Project
guys. And that dad took it down to the
sub-basement of this building where the
hot room was. So there's a like
three-foot thick wall of leaded glass
with manipulator arms and on the other
side of it is incredibly radioactive
stuff. And so that dad took the corn
seeds and put them next to really
radioactive stuff for differing amounts
of time. And then painted them
different colors. The red
ones had been really exposed to a lot of
radiation and you know so on and so forth. And then
those were handed out to us at the next
meeting of the Boy Scout troop.
And the assignment was to plant them and cultivate these seeds and then after a
month, we bring the plants in and there'd
be a prize given out for the tallest,
healthiest corn plant, and another prize
for the weirdest mutation. And this is
all completely deadpan, no hoopla, no
sense of how weird this was. That's like
yes, one of the things you do in Boy
Scouts, grow mutant plants. So
that's kind of where I came from.
So I studied scientific type
topics in school but I always reserved
some hope that I might be able to make a
living as a writer as well. And so I just
didn't study it because I figured I
could kind of work that on my own and so
then after I graduated from college I
started writing books. And on the
third one I got very lucky, a whole bunch
of things randomly fell into place for
me. And I got an agent, I got an editor I
was able to publish a book and so so
that's what I ended up doing. KEVIN KELLY: So you've never had a real job?
STEPHENSON: Well, I've had real shitty jobs. lf you mean like a career kind of path job I've
not really had one of those.